hey everyone it is just past five am
kind of tired but I am heading off to
microsoft in redmond at just outside of
Seattle I'm part of their influence of
program and they're flying me out there
to check out all the new stuff that
Microsoft is up to to help entrepreneurs
so I'm going to check it out and give
you guys an update I settled into the
terminal I got a coffee because I'm
gonna need it i had about four hours
sleep and i'm going to be going from 5am
today until 9pm the idle time I think
that's why I supposed to get back to my
hotel which will be midnight my time so
from five a.m. to midnight on four hours
sleep gonna need a coffee or two and
getting ready to go Nina woke up with me
at 5am driving to the airport thank you
babe love you miss you're ready I'll see
you soon and looking forward to getting
the show on the road
time for my second tim hortons of the
day hmm
welcome to Seattle
alright so I'm here at the westin hotel
Paul the next two days really tired from
time is my time it is 413 I've been
enough for almost 12 hours basically
just traveling so I'm going to find my
room get a quick shower a change and
then they're waiting on me at
Microsoft's Office so
bathroom TV is on nice bed we got a view
view of Bellevue the Bellevue view not a
lot of time to take it all in though
shower change often Microsoft it is
amazing what a shower and some water
will do I'm feeling refreshed energized
I've got my business casual leçons is
really I always look on got the believe
hoodie the pains the five toe shoes
ready to rock it with Microsoft hurry my
building number 4 i'm going to go in
there I mean up with the party find my
contact and see what I'm going to learn
I'm not allowed to film inside because
there's some high secrecy new things
that are coming out that are really
exciting that I can't share with you
guys yet but it's coming soon full so a
bunch of us where all the entrepreneur
experts here are in the lobby we're
going to do a selfie we're gonna do
selfie Barry's got a stick oh no it's
bordick you rely mommy mom like you're
gonna yes you tUnE taking the shuttle to
go check out some tech at Microsoft
we're on the Microsoft shuttle going to
check out their new secret stuff
separately secret card we're always
secret hardware that said I'm not
allowed to film
in trouble getting in trouble so I share
but it's gonna be cool I'm excited steve
has a special message this is the top
secret building that I'm not allowed to
film inside I'm excited to see what we
get so we are leaving top-secret
building highlight I was a highlight
Barry I have to say one of the highlight
was the quietest room at world where
itís room in the world yeah me too it
was very cool I think that's the only
thing we're allowed to talk about
everything else I think what was very
interesting was how you know it's all
integrated together where the
development the research people they all
work coming together to make sure that
the why don't I need the stuff the stuff
comes out sooner dinner and then bed i'm
crashing i'm crashing hard how you doing
you're holding that you look like you
got energy i'm doing ok i'm doing ok i
get a second wind are you east coast now
I'm central your central it's not a big
of time difference didn't dinner a big
Italian food hang on and sleep and then
up it up for seven seven o'clock
tomorrow morning these are is our
shuttle something like that yeah
something crazy 730 all right back on
board our Microsoft shuttle we get the
private table upstairs
okay she's back at the hotel a super fun
day had some yummy food met some great
people got some swag got my microsoft
surface pro 3 let's open this up quick
we'll open up quick does not come out of
the package quickly okay I will open it
up tomorrow I am crashing hard I don't
even know what time it is is late plus 3
hours for timezone gotta be up and
meeting them at seven thirty tomorrow
morning so I will report back then
shower talk to Nina go to bed goodnight
it's just about six just woke up I set
my alarm for seven but crazy noisy
neighbor so I'm up early so shower
connect even get to talk to Nina maybe a
little work done and then go meet my
crew and off the Microsoft for day two I
look I've ever made coffee in a hotel
room gonna give it a shot can't be that
hard right now and of course it's
starbucks being in Seattle it smells so
good so I'm checking in on my email and
Christina wants me to get ahead on the
believe life series and I haven't had a
lot of time to check in on the videos
usually when I go away the evenings are
pretty open in the mornings don't start
so early Microsoft is really giving us a
lot of information which is good but
that means I haven't had as much time to
follow up with everything so the believe
life series is always our most
challenging one it's the most amount of
back and forth and now it's on me I love
reviewing every single video before it
goes out it has a Evan stamp of approval
so I'm gonna look at that and then I
want to check out the swag that I got
the surface pro 3 and check that out and
then go meet my team for breakfast
hopefully I had time for everything
so I've been watching the videos of the
believe life by the time I guess this
video goes live the believe life video
on overcoming procrastination should
already be live I'm super excited I got
changed while ozols into the videos and
watching them Christina and I have an
amazing job and putting that betta
together and I just proposed this is me
and my crazy thought I always have to
change things up and put Christina on
her toes love you Kristina I thought
there were a number of extra really good
clips that were not included and I find
sometimes we get this on our top 10
videos as well where there's 10 great
roles but then there's also so much
footage sometimes we don't sometimes
it's hard because sometimes it's a hard
finding good footage of entrepreneurs
but sometimes we have bonus because
there's so much more and on the
procrastination one is some extra
footage I think it'd be really helpful
so what I think I'm going to do on this
one I guess it's already the city
already been made if you guys have
watched it this is coming out after is
too at the end of the very video show
some bonus clips and I think I might
apply this to the top 10 too so we have
our top 10 than my extra and then the
logo and then bonus clips if they apply
I'm thinking up to 3 bonus clips if they
are really really good so I'm hoping we
test on this one let me know what you
think if you want to see those bonus
clips leave it in the comments below I
am rushing I gotta get ready to go I
wasn't able to open the surface pro so
I'm going to bring it with me and
onwards went down with Allah be met with
everybody chit-chatting and then
realized i forgot my Fitbit so i gotta
run back to the hotel room get my Fitbit
me everybody in the shuttle bus and then
head to microsoft
you
i'm pretty sure it's in my robe haha
there it is how many steps today 845 wow
that's really bad alright let's go let's
go let's go okay day two I caused a
ruckus on the bus by bringing up the
American election and all these guys
have different views and opinions so I'm
not allowed to speak on the bus go back
to your health care your banking system
well it's really Canada oh let these
guys get away with it cuz I'm in hostile
territory down here no we love everybody
loves Haiti and Yvonne supported this
diamond trader Canadian who says
America's the greatest country it's all
good my audience is mostly American
anyway so you're Canadian show support
leave a comment below no filming I'm
done alright day is over leaving
Microsoft I'm able to fill him again
cameras allowed to be turned on super
excited thoughts on the day pretty
exciting Microsoft's doing a lot more
cool stuff that I thought they were and
unfortunately not allowed to share a lot
of the stuff that I saw today which kind
of sucks but excited to test a few
things in my business and see how that
goes and if I get results with it I'll
share it with you guys give some
recommendations about to get on the bus
but Jennifer price who's been on the
channel you guys have seen her a couple
times and the hangouts lives in Portland
and she's going to be meeting me at the
hotel she's already there actually so I
just found out Portland's of a three
hour drive from where we are so she
drove three hours up and we're gonna go
grab a bite maybe got some drinks do
some videos and introduce you to the
channel again in purse is my first time
meeting her face to face with done tons
of hangouts together the first time in
your face to face so I'm excited see you
soon
I think that Evan should bring us some
Microsoft Technology with him i'm going
to try hi have a great flight okay let's
find jen there she is jennifer price in
the house live in flesh how you doing
how are you good hidden well that was a
lot of fun my throat is so hoarse we
ended up talking for hours it's 1030 I
should I shouldn't talk so loud and
embrace asleep it's 1030 way later than
I thought I forgot the film our
conversation or dinner or anything just
kind of got lost its fun this Jen and I
have worked together for a while never
met her and she drove two and a half
hours to get here so that was awesome
tired though it's 1030 which means it's
130 for me got to get up at I guess five
tomorrow Oh get on the airplane come
home I see my wife so break excited for
that I haven't been able to talk to her
since I've been here my schedule has
been insanely packed which is rare
because usually this there's times in
the day but anyway crashing hard going
to go in and sleep
all right I'm on my way don't want to
make a lot of noise and still early
super tired only ended sleeping about
three hours i want to say whenever I
have an early morning flight I'm always
paranoid that I'm not going to wake up
in time and then I end up not sleeping I
feel my body physically crashing on me
excited to go home except the Z Nina I
don't know if I'll sleep on the plane
probably not but apply crash as soon as
I get home and that's it you're going to
drive it to the flight back breakfast
time I'm excited that the pumpkin spice
frappuccino is back at starbucks oh yeah
love ya too big ol to eat and I'm gonna
go check him down some email bigwig
behind christina is gonna kill me
because I'm so far behind and doing the
videos from kill me Christina
and hopefully I have enough time to
check in on the stuff that she needs
before get in the plane and come in how
they have these little personal
workstations that you can plug in get
online and do some work so that's where
I'm going to be until the plane things
up I just notice what they wrote on my
Starbucks cup one in what the heck that
is top carbon cowan what do you guys
think leaving the comments below ok so
just lined it on the flight I was
getting more and more tired and drained
and exhausted and a little angry I'm
tired haven't slept much but I landed
i'm excited to see Nina it's going to be
back here in Toronto I hope she's here
last time you know was late been to the
airport Christina let's show the footage
and i'm pretty sure just gonna be here
because she has the day off so let's see
if we can find her i'm very excited
let's see where she is
there she is she's on her phone
Nina
there she is here she comes hey didn't I
meet you in Mexico missed you nah there
she is that's it I gotta go home and say
so thanks for joining I don't really
have a question let me know you think of
the video leave a comment you know what
to say something how much you missed me
a lot a lot okay bye guys believe